[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 j'espère que
vous allez bien nous sommes le mercredi
8 février voici le programme de ce soir
on part dans l'espace le musée de la
ville de Montigny-le-Bretonneux lance
une nouvelle exposition sur la conquête
spatiale jusqu'au 8 juillet vous pourrez
découvrir comment cette période de
l'histoire a influencé la décoration
intérieure nous retrouverons sur place
notre journaliste Nicolas dandry il sera
avec Frédéric debuch le conservateur du
musée dans un mois c'est la clôture des
vœux sur la plateforme parcoursup les
lycéens ont jusqu'au 9 mars pour faire
leur choix d'orientation pour les aider
tous les mercredis nous partons à la
découverte d'une formation du territoire
avec notre journaliste Régine ralech ce
soir focus sur l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin on Yvelines
avec un étudiant un master de droit
Benjamin colo et comme chaque mercredi
nous parlerons également de cinéma dans
votre 7 8 ce soir nous serons avec la
réalisatrice et productrice Géna sur rue
que vous avez déjà aperçu dans les coups
de coeurs ciné elle préside la cinquième
édition du Festival international du
film avec notamment à l'affiche
l'actrice Clémentine Célarié le film de
l'actrice Clémentine Célarié et comme
d'habitude nous ferons le point sur les
films à ne pas manquer dans les salles
de cinéma ce sera tout à l'heure enfin
des missions mais tout de suite on
retrouve génacerus pour le lancement de
son cinquième festival Vienna sur rue
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de créer votre propre festival
bon ah merci bienvenue au Festival
international du film de Paris je suis
juin par Ethan qui présente en
court-métrage sisi qui est listé pour
les Oscars et qui se finira vendredi
pourquoi ce festival c'est justement
pour inviter des films Maker à venir du
monde entier puisque Tom vient de Rome
donc c'est des cinéastes qui viennent du
monde entier vous avez d'autres Inès
avec vous oui oui tout à fait justement
on va on va vous les présenter donc on
espère que techniquement ça va
fonctionner mais
parce que là vous êtes en plein Paris
faut peut-être le préciser vous êtes à
côté du cinéma Le Champeau qui est situé
à Paris exactement et pour ceux qui sont
encore dans le RER vous pouvez toujours
nous rejoindre des 78
et alors peut-être juste avant de
retrouver les cinéastes quel est le
principe de ce festival Jenna sur rue
alors c'est pas pour rien qu'on est sur
rue des Écoles puisque le festival a
avant tout vocation à promouvoir
l'éducationnelle et la francophilie
c'est pour ça que nos réalisateurs que
vous pouvez d'ailleurs entre parsevoir
d'ici puisqu'ils sont au premier étage
de ce magnifique restaurant parisien
viennent des 5 continents depuis le
début de la semaine ils prennent ici
leur film nous avons des panels et des
discussions également un laboratoire en
collaboration avec la fabrique des
récits et l'objectif c'est avant tout de
développement international l'inclusion
dans les dans nos fictions et plus
largement on espère dans nos vies
et donc il y aura aussi des remises des
prix à la fin
tout à fait le festival ouvre ce soir
avec le premier long métrage de
Clémentine Célarié dont vous avez parlé
qui est formidable c'est un film qui
s'appelle Pierre et Jeanne son premier
long-métrage du réalisatrice et le
festival se poursuit jusqu'au 15 février
avec la remise de prix et le 14 février
un moyen-métrage Suisse qui a été nominé
aux scar l'année dernière et qui parle
de la liberté on vous donne tous
rendez-vous juste ici alors je rebondis
vous avez parlé du film de Clémentine
Célarié qui a réalisé du coup Pierre et
Jeanne on va en parler juste après mais
avant regardons un extrait de ce film de
la bande-annonce
décédé
[Musique]
à votre fille Jeanne demoiselle Jeanne
Holland c'est très généreux
merci mon frère merci
mon compte à rien de toi
alors ce film il tourne autour d'un
frère et d'une sœur c'est un peu une
histoire
déchirante entre le frère et sa sœur et
du coup Clémentine Célarié s'est inspiré
du livre Pierre et Jean de Guy de
Maupassant
absolument et pour raconter cette
histoire à la rassembler un casque
absolument exceptionnel Loris Freeman
Philippe huchant également avec la
participation de Mathieu Amalric c'est
formidable parce que nous ici au
Festival international du film de Paris
on est vraiment très heureux de célébrer
le cinéma indépendant là il s'agit d'un
premier film il s'agit aussi d'un pour
le festival avant à long métrage
australien précédemment vu au Festival
de Cannes dans la section civile et
c'est formidable de pouvoir raconter une
histoire de famille il faut dire qu'ici
pour cette cinquième édition
anniversaire nous mettons vraiment à
l'honneur le thème de la famille de la
parenté puisque les courts métrages dont
le film d'Ethan Sissi près justement de
ces thèmes qui sont à nos yeux très
importants et qu'on a vraiment tenu à
mettre en valeur cette semaine alors
durant le festival sera également
diffusé le documentaire Pioneer pioneer
in scurt désolé pour pour l'accent c'est
pionnière en jupe en français ce
documentaire il met notamment en avant
les obstacles que peuvent rencontrer
les femmes durant leur carrière
absolument et c'est vrai que le thème de
l'inclusion est très important pour nous
et il est important dans nos fictions il
est également important dans nos
industries et le Festival international
du film de Paris à vocation avant tout
de rassembler un public de
professionnels d'amateurs et également
d'étudiants et l'idée c'est de réfléchir
ensemble comment est-ce qu'on va
construire le monde de demain donc dès
demain après les festivités de
l'ouverture se tiendra le laboratoire
des scénaristes en partenariat avec
network
Issa et la fabrique des récits ainsi que
l'association Ensemble Ukraine qui fait
un premier absolument phénoménal et avec
ce laboratoire qui est inaugural pour
cette année l'idée c'est de continuer à
travailler ensemble pour trouver des
solutions dans nos fictions et dans nos
vies pour justement rendre cette
bataille moins difficile et pour
toujours parler plus de cinéma
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu les autres films qui seront à
l'affiche
oui tout à fait nous avons une très
belle sélection de longs métrages de
courts métrages également de scénarios
que j'ai mentionné on n'oublie pas bien
sûr à la chou donc le moyen-métrage
Suisse déjà mentionné qui est réalisé
par Maria Brandon nous sommes très
honorés de recevoir ce film la semaine
prochaine puisqu'il s'agit d'un film
nominé aux Oscars qui traite d'un thème
tout à fait universel celui de la
liberté dans le cadre en l'occurrence
d'une famille au Kirghistan et
l'objectif de la réalisatrice Maria
Brandon avec ce film c'est de faire en
sorte que tout le monde dans le monde
entier sache que lorsqu'une femme au
Kirghizstan souhaite se libérer de ces
nouveaux proches imposées et bien la loi
est de son côté donc encore une fois on
revient sur le thème de l'éducationnel
qui est si cher au festival
et bien merci beaucoup Diana sur rue
d'avoir accepté notre invitation du coup
si vous êtes intéressé le pari
International Film Festival aura lieu
jusqu'au 15 février dans le cinéma à
parisien le Champeau si vous êtes
intéressé vous pouvez retrouver plus
d'informations sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en dessous de votre écran bon
festival alors dans cette émission nous
serons également avec la reine du muguet
et ces dauphines ce sera enfin démission
mais juste avant je tends un coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin nous devrions avoir un ciel voilé
sur l'ensemble du département au niveau
des températures il fera toujours aussi
froid compter moins 3 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet et moins
2 degrés à Versailles et Houdan dans
l'après-midi nous devrions toujours
avoir un grand soleil ça fait du bien
côté température météo France prévoit 6
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles et 5 degrés à Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Apolline
le pour maintenant sur l'information
d'un de les Yvelines avec Michael elle
mie d'euro
une nouvelle manifestation ce mercredi
des agriculteurs du sud-yvelines ont
défilé aujourd'hui avec leur tracteur à
Paris il dénonce l'arrêt brutale de
l'usage des néonicotinoïdes un pesticide
pour les cultures de betterave qui
empêchent la jaunisse une maladie virale
propagée par les pucerons la filière
pensée bénéficier d'une dérogation comme
cela était prévu au total une vingtaine
de tracteurs du département rejoint par
des tracteurs d'Eure-et-Loir se sont
retrouvés au niveau d'Ablis pour se
rendre à la capitale pour rejoindre plus
de 500 tracteurs et 2000 paysans à
déménagement à présent la société Airbus
va quitter la clé de Saint-Pierre à
Élancourt pour s'installer à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dans le quartier
du pas du lac à l'horizon 2027 en cause
le manque de transport en commun dans la
zone élancourtoise et un bail qui
arrivait à expiration le groupe
d'aéronautique et de défense va lancer
des études en vue de la réalisation de
ce nouveau site à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
les travaux devraient s'assuer fin 2026
au total 2700 salariés sont concernés à
Coignières l'association pharmacie
citoyen fondée par Mustapha lahbaoui a
organisé comme dit un goûter sale
Saint-Exupéry l'idée était de réunir les
enfants et les parents de neuf club
locaux de football amateurs partenaires
de l'association retrouvé par exemple
les présidents des clubs de Guyancourt
Élancourt au plaisir l'objectif était
également de présenter les sorties
organisées par la structure sur la
citoyenneté les valeurs de la République
on fait 30 sorties au total je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure à 4 mini bus à chaque
fois
cinq destinations
c'est quasiment 80000 km par an et bien
ça sert c'est les sorties sont éducatifs
et j'aime bien ça fait plaisir de penser
aux petits enfants comme nous voilà
c'est c'est cool de ouf c'est trop bon
2024 les organisateurs ont présenté ce
mercredi l'identité visuelle de chaque
discipline avec les différents
pictogrammes et les couleurs dominantes
de la compétition le rose le bleu le
violet et l'or seront les couleurs qui
habilleront les sites les villes et les
partenaires en 2024 les Yvelines vont
accueillir le cyclisme sur piste le BMX
le VTT le golfe l'équitation le marathon
le pentathlon moderne le cyclisme sur
route on termine par de la box chez les
lots en connaît enfin la date du combat
entre livinois Tony yokai Carlos Takam
affrontement est programmé le 11 mars au
Zénith de la Porte de la Villette à
Paris un choc de style en perspective
entre les deux boxeurs Tony hawka 30 ans
11 victoires et une défaite va affronter
un vétéran de 42 ans qui compte 39
victoires 7 défaites et un nul le boxeur
originaire de Chanteloup-les-Vignes aura
à cœur de se rattraper après sa première
défaite chez les professionnels contre
Martin à bas collé en mai dernier
dans l'actualité également la
manifestation des agriculteurs qui a eu
lieu aujourd'hui à Paris le
déclenchement de cette mobilisation
l'interdiction par le gouvernement
d'utiliser l'insecticide
néonicotinoïde à la fin du mois de
janvier François Lecoq bonsoir
bonsoir à vous alors vous êtes encore
dans votre voiture vous essayez de
revenir dans les Yvelines vous êtes
agriculteur et administrateur de la
fédération départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles d'Île-de-France
et du coup vous étiez ce matin
aujourd'hui à Paris pour manifester
contre contre cette décision du
gouvernement d'interdire le pesticide
néo
nicotinoïdes alors cette décision c'est
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase pour les agriculteurs oui c'est la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
en fait on n'était pas la queue pour les
néo
l'idée c'est de dire aussi au ce
gouvernement c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
fait partie de l'Europe
la France était premier producteur
européen il y a 10 ans aujourd'hui on
est dixième on ne produit plus que 50%
de ce qu'on consomme en France et on ne
comprend pas dans quel dans quel
direction on nous emmène puisqu'en nous
retirant encore cette matière active sur
la betterave bien entendu la betterave
va s'arrêter en France parce que ce
n'est pas possible de produire de la
betterave sans cette insecticide mais
les autres pays européens l'Allemagne la
Pologne et la Roumanie vont continuer à
à produire du sucre avec ce produit
qu'on fera après venir en France donc on
est surtout sur le fait de dire arrêtons
d'importer ce qui ne répond pas aux
normes qu'on nous impose agriculteurs
français
François Le Coq si vous pouvez juste
essayer de reculer un tout petit peu
votre visage de l'écran peut-être qu'on
vous verra plus en intégralité ce sera
mieux du coup pour revenir sur la
néonicotinuite c'est quand même un
pesticide qui tuait qui était
dévastateur pour la biodiversité et de
l'environnement puisqu'il tue tous les
insectes sont distinction vous demandez
quoi aujourd'hui au gouvernement que que
cette interdiction elle soit globalisée
à toute l'Union européenne
voilà on demande que s'il est interdit
en France il doit être interdit dans
toute leur peuple pas on ne peut pas
être des règles différentes d'un pays à
l'autre là on est dans une dans quelque
chose d'incompréhensible et c'est sur
les betteraves mais c'est sur les
cerises c'est sur les salades c'est sur
la pomme de terre c'est-à-dire qu'on va
plus de produits
merci
et les légumes et les fruits les fruits
et légumes aussi c'est incroyable
merci François Lecoq on va mettre fin à
cet entretien puisse enfin le son est
assez haché on va vous laisser rentrer
tranquillement dans les Yvelines merci
en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on en parlait en début de
démission le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines lance une
nouvelle exposition autour de l'espace
où on retrouve sur place notre
journaliste Nicolas dandry bonsoir
Nicolas
bonsoir Mathilde vous êtes avec le
conservateur du musée de Monsieur debuch
et alors est-ce qu'on peut voir au sein
de cette exposition Nicolas
et bien écoutez le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous plonge
nous plonge pardons dans le spaceage
quand la conquête spatiale inspire le
design et bien écoutez en fait à la fin
des années de guerre de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la conquête spatiale est
lancée et inspire le design les produits
du quotidien et pour en parler nous
sommes avec Frédéric debuch le directeur
du musée de la ville bonjour
peut-être les différentes formes
d'inspiration et à travers ces exemples
on a déjà voulu commencer par le nom
puisque on a ici des exemples d'un
designer qui s'appelle case Arcan et qui
a créé une gamme qui s'appelle Aerospace
et qui consiste notamment de mobilier
gonflable et donc on est dans la
thématique de l'air de l'aérien et avec
cette esthétique aussi qui est tout à
fait tout à fait spécifique mais autre
objet et la table nuage d'un autre d'un
autre designer nuage parce que voilà on
voulait aussi rappeler que la conquête
de l'espace était d'abord un élan vers
le cosmos vers le ciel et vers
autre objet assez surprenant et bien
c'est cette télévision parce que oui
c'est une télévision voilà c'est
exactement c'est une télévision c'est un
objet qui est assez explicite de ce que
peut et assez démonstratif de ce que
peut être le spécial avec là une
aspiration vraiment très direct alors
c'est une télévision japonaise
créée par un designer qui s'appelle
Fujita et qui a qui s'est tout
simplement inspiré du casque du
cosmonaute donc la télé est parfaitement
ronde et devant l'écran il y a une
visière bombée dans un plexiglas un
petit peu plus fumé qui rappelle
évidemment le casque du cosmonaute c'est
aussi une télé qui avait la
particularité de d'être portative qui
pouvait être déplacé d'une pièce à
l'autre de la maison et qui peut être
suspendu par levier d'une chaîne et donc
on imagine dans une pièce en suspension
et là elle prend plus tellement l'allure
d'un casque de cosmonaute mais plutôt
d'une planète qui serait en suspension
dans l'espace et surprenant c'est que ça
date des années 70 alors cette télé date
précisément de 1970 et donc elle a été
conçu l'année précédente en 69
exactement elle est donc sa conception
est exactement contemporaine de la
mission Apollo 11 qui a vu la conquête
de la Lune et c'est sans doute en lien
direct avec cette aventure que le
designer japonais a conçu cette
télévision ce qui rappelle aussi
d'ailleurs que le spacege là on est chez
JBC que le Space est vraiment un style
international qu'on trouve en Europe aux
États-Unis mais aussi en Asie une
dernière question sur le choix pourquoi
ce choix du musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de faire cette
exposition alors ce choix parce que tout
d'abord le musée de la ville possède une
grande collection publique en matière de
design qui est surtout orienté sur les
années 60 70 80 et cette thématique du
spaceage et justement une thématique de
ces années-là donc comme on avait traité
par exemple précédemment en 2022 la
question de la couleur orange qui est
très très seventies euh le sujet aussi
de prise unique il était normal qu'on
qu'on aborde cette question là la
conquête de l'espace qui constitue une
en matière de design ou d'architecture
Vardar une une composante vraiment
naturelle de la culture pop de de ces
années-là merci beaucoup Frédéric debuch
voilà Mathilde sur cette exposition au
musée de la ville sur le Space Age je
sais que vous êtes passionné par le
sujet spatial Mathilde je sais que vous
souhaitez y aller et bien je vais vous
donner tout de suite les informations
vous pouvez y aller si vous êtes
intéressé par cette exposition à partir
du 10 février et c'est jusqu'au 8
juillet c'est ouvert le mardi le
mercredi le vendredi et le samedi de 14h
à 18h l'entrée est gratuite alors ben
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à plonger
dans les étoiles
merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry pour
toutes ces précisions on va revenir sur
Terre maintenant on va faire notre focus
sur une école et une formation c'est
tout de suite après
alors je vous le disais comme chaque
mercredi maintenant nous partons à la
découverte d'une école ou d'une
formation dans les Yvelines et c'est
avec vous Régina rage bonsoir bonsoir
alors ce soir vous allez nous parler de
propriété intellectuelle et de droit du
numérique tout à fait Mathilde et c'est
l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui délivre la
formation pidan c'est à dire propriété
intellectuelle et droit des affaires
numériques on a avec nous Benjamin
Collot bonsoir vous êtes étudiants en
Master 2 dans cette formation est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire plus précisément
ce que signifie propriété intellectuelle
et droit des affaires numériques la
propriété intellectuelle c'est deux pans
du droit qui comprend notamment le droit
d'auteur la contrefaçon de marque et les
brevets et aussi tout plein d'autres
domaines du droit d'avoir le droit des
contrats par exemple on ne citer que ça
au sein de l'espace du numérique en fait
tout simplement est-ce que vous avez un
exemple à peu près
mon achat sur Amazon il y a pas mal
d'interactions qui se passe à ce
moment-là et c'est sur ça que nous en
tant que juriste ou avocat on
s'intéresse en tout cas on s'intéresse
aux enjeux autour de ça parce qu'il y a
évidemment une source économique
importante dans au sein du numérique et
pour ne pas aussi citer les données un
caractère personnel rgpd tout ça ça vous
dit ça vous évoque quelque chose et
justement cette formation elle est
délivrée par l'UVSQ et en quelques
chiffres le master de bidon c'est 25
étudiants chaque année 300 heures de
cours un taux d'employabilité a presque
100%, un salaire médian à 2400 euros à
la sortie de l'école et en termes de
débouchés plusieurs métiers s'offrent à
vous comme consultant juriste ou avocat
en droit du numérique alors Benjamin
Collot vous avez un petit peu développé
ce que vous apprenez aujourd'hui en
Master 2 mais vous êtes passé par quel
parcours en fait vous avez fait une
licence d'abord moi j'ai fait une double
licence droit et LLCER anglais mais on
peut accéder de la formation on est en
simplement fait une licence de droit
tout ça donc pourquoi pourquoi ce choix
vous avez commencé
par moi en sortant du lycée j'avais une
certaine appétence pour l'anglais donc
j'avais envie de garder ça et le droit
m'intéressait énormément et puis au fur
et à mesure étant passionné de musique
je me suis le droit de la musique m'a
beaucoup intéressé et donc je me suis
tourné vers la propriété intellectuelle
et comme à l'heure actuelle tout ce qui
est question de streaming par exemple ou
téléchargement illégal sont des
questions qui sont vraiment d'actualité
je passe mes journées à étudier ça et
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je me suis
tourné vers ces études et justement dans
ce master quelles sont les cours que
vous voyez j'ai un cours de droit de la
musique par exemple sinon j'ai de la
protection des données personnelles ou
par exemple là on va étudier tout ce qui
est cookies en fait ce qu'ils ont droit
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de
mettre directement le fait que vous
puissiez tout refuser c'est une des
avancées du rgpd aussi
le règlement général sur la protection
des
sortir en 2016 si je vous dis pas de
bêtises mais voilà et donc dedans il y a
un tas de un tas de comment dirige de
lois qui s'intéresse à toutes ces
questions entre vous chers internaute et
les fournisseurs que ce soit par exemple
les gafams
Google Facebook Amazon etc etc et du
coup vous avez dû faire ou vous avez
fait
des notes Masters
qui prenait pas mal de temps et donc on
était pas obligé de faire un stage
maintenant il y a 100% de d'étudiants
qui trouvent dans notre formation en
tout cas un stage dans la spécialité de
leur choix et mais c'est vivement
encouragé de faire des stages avant le
master si vous en avez la possibilité et
pendant le master pendant le master
c'est obligatoire à la fin du Master 2
on commence cette année j'ai
effectivement un stage et donc vous
allez faire votre stage dans quoi moi
j'aimerais bien viser ouais tout ce qui
est maison de disque en fait tout ce qui
est édition musicale
c'est vraiment ce qui m'intéresse le
plus et notamment quand je vous ai
évoqué tout à l'heure la question du
streaming moi c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui m'intéresse énormément et donc
voilà j'aimerais travailler au sein de
ces sociétés afin de poursuivre un peu
mêlés droit travail et passion entre
guillemets
justement vous dites que vous aimez le
secteur musical donc il y a énormément
d'enjeux quel métier ce qu'on peut faire
dans ce secteur
que ce soit pour la maison de 10 pour
être avocat pour un artiste ou juriste
au sein d'une entreprise dans l'édition
musicale c'est vraiment les grands
changements et sinon notre formation
permet aussi de de devenir ce qu'ils
appellent aujourd'hui des PO qui sont en
gros les personnes référentes dans les
entreprises pour les données et voilà
donc ça vu que maintenant c'est
obligatoire par le rgpd ça ouvre quand
même pas mal de portes et surtout un
nombre de secteurs en fait vraiment très
varié est-ce que dans cette formation
vous trouvez qu'il y a un point fort
quelque chose qui vous a vraiment aidé
qui vous aidera en tout cas dans votre
quotidien à la sortie de l'école c'est
un master qui court énormément quand
vous avez pu le remarquer qui courait
énormément de données et c'est quand
même une formation plus de la moitié des
courses on fait par des professionnels
donc ça c'est quand même un énorme
avantage et surtout pour moi le point
fort vraiment de ma formation ce sont le
fait que les étudiants sont vraiment
poussés à mener des projets personnels
et je sais mon camarade qui est parti au
Japon avec une université qui était pas
conventionnée à la base mais qui a monté
un projet et qui avec l'aide des
directrices de Master a pu partir au
Japon six mois c'est quoi son projet
bien travailler si je dis pas de bêtises
dans le secteur audiovisuel en fait et
mais du coup au Japon donc il est parti
au
japonais et puis apprendre un peu plus
sur les lois nationales là-bas parce que
évidemment c'est même plus on est en
dehors de l'Europe donc c'est vraiment
un cadre totalement différent là on est
sur droit international que ma formation
très tôt aussi du coup parce que là les
enjeux autour de notre formation le
demande d'avoir un côté vraiment
international quoi et du coup si vous
aviez des conseils à donner aux
étudiants au lycéen qui veulent rentrer
en fait peut-être qu'on va commencer par
la licence parce que c'est vrai que
passer du lycée à la fac c'est pas
facile est-ce que vous vous aviez vous
avez des conseils alors passer du lycée
à la fac moi je dirais c'est se
connaître en fait c'est peut-être le
truc le plus important moi
personnellement ça a mis du temps mais
donc si ça peut rassurer certains ça
arrive souvent au cours des études
supérieures pour la plupart d'ailleurs
mais non sinon je dirais d'être curieux
et de d'essayer de d'avoir une réflexe
en
[Musique]
énormément d'actualité c'est vraiment le
je pense le
principal vraiment à voir c'est vraiment
s'intéresser aux questions d'actualité
puis évidemment lire ce qui s'est passé
avant afin de comprendre mieux comment
ça se passe maintenant voilà je pense
c'est vraiment le principal conseil
c'était resté branché c'était à
l'actualité
merci beaucoup d'être venu en plateau
pour nous parler de votre formation on
va prendre la direction de
Triel-sur-Seine maintenant depuis deux
ans la commune organise chaque mois des
cours de self défense pour les femmes en
collaboration avec la police municipale
le reportage de Régine ralech et de
Nicolas dendry
être une femme seule dans la rue ou dans
les transports en commun n'est pas
centraka c'est pourquoi la ville de
Triel-sur-Seine organise chaque mois des
cours d'autodéfense pour les femmes
j'étais étudiante sur Paris avant et
c'est vrai que je me suis fait agresser
de nombreuses fois dans les transports
et et sur Paris
et c'est vrai que je j'avais besoin de
de connaître les moyens de défense en
fait au cas où ça se reproduise on se
sent pas à l'aise dans la rue Antoine
dans notamment dans le train dans le
métro dans le RER c'est souvent
pour nous à risquer enfin je trouve oui
il y a les pouces au niveau des yeux ça
va faire lâcher la structure maintenant
au bassin il est comment
donc là le coup de genou
ces gestes ne sont pas anodins et
pourtant il pourrait sauver des vies
Pascal ce formateur en self-défense
insiste sur l'attitude et les bons
gestes pour se défendre en cas de danger
on s'adresse à des femmes ou des mères
de famille qui n'ont pas forcément du
temps à consacrer à aller en club dans
une association à prendre des gestes
compliqué qui demandent x répétition là
on fait appel à souvent à Liné qu'on
sent des gestes très très simple pour
neutraliser une personne temporairement
sur des zones qu'on appelle entre
guillemets molle qui vont fonctionner
sur tout type de gabarit en fait
certaines d'entre elles assistent au
cours de manière régulière un moyen
rassurant et efficace non c'est très
simple et en fait on se rend compte que
on peut se défendre de tout nos propres
moyens et après il suffit de d'avoir les
gestes principales on a appris à se
défendre quand on est prise par
l'arrière l'avant
[Musique]
avec un sac à main en 2022 près de 300
femmes ont assisté au cours de celles
déf thématique du prochain rendez-vous
se défendre avec des objets du quotidien
c'est une tradition à Rambouillet qui
existe depuis plus de 90 ans la nouvelle
reine du muguet 2023 est connu et elle
est en plateau avec nous Jessica Gomez
bonsoir bonsoir et du coup vous êtes
accompagné de vos dauphines de dauphines
et mis en Sarthe bonsoir bonsoir et de
Lise Carlin bonsoir alors c'est un peu
la coutume vous devez être accompagné de
vos dauphines à chaque fois que vous
vous déplacez parce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi
parce que souvent la reine va pas être
toute seule je pense faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée toujours de ses dauphines
d'accord et alors en quoi est-ce que ça
consiste exactement concrètement le rôle
de la reine du muguet alors la reine
tout au long de l'année
alors
et avec
de venir aux convention qu'on est invité
c'est des inégaux des innovations
et donc ce rôle de reine du muguet en
fait c'est aussi le rôle des Dauphines
tous ces rôles que vous avez cités là
c'est aussi votre rôle à vous de oui
et vous devez également représenter des
associations
lesquels vous aviez représenté ou vous
représentez toujours alors moi c'est
l'association l'Amicale
franco-portugaise moi c'était le poney
club du veillant de Rambouillet et moi
j'ai choisi le Nautic Club de
Rambouillet et alors pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé de vous lancer dans de
ce concours Miss muguet
bah également pour présenter la ville
représenter nos associations je pense
aussi
c'est une chose aussi à laquelle on
tient parce que depuis petite aussi on
voit tout le temps les chars défilés
donc le 13 et le 14
dont la reine du muguet aussi c'est une
tradition très ancrée sous la ville de
Rambouillet du coup c'est un peu une
fierté pour vous ça représente quoi pour
pour vous trois d'avoir été sélectionnés
c'est quelque chose de très beau on
vivra ça qu'une seule fois dans notre
vie
on partage toutes les trois
et du coup quels sont quelles sont les
critères de sélection pour pour arriver
à Rennes et Dauphine du muguet il y en a
pas faut juste avoir une association en
manque si je peux dire d'accord et c'est
tout il y a pas vraiment un critère
à tout le monde et ensuite comment
comment est-ce que vous êtes élu c'est
par qui il y avait des votes sur
Internet cette année c'était la première
fois qu'il faisait ça c'est nouveau par
mail vote dans les journaux aussi dans
les journaux
d'accord et alors comment ça se passe la
soirée alors il y a des associations de
toutes les candidates plus les amis de
la famille qui viennent aussi pour nous
voir et ensuite il y a
7000 là on a eu donc le cabaret de
Rambouillet qui est venu et ensuite
on nous présente etc et les gens par la
suite qui vote du coup le vote en salle
et ces associations justement ça leur
permet d'être mise en lumière comment ça
se passe c'est ça c'est pour valoriser
les associations apporter de la lumière
comme vous avez dit et voilà il y a des
choses qui sont faites avec les
associations durant l'année où vous êtes
mis ces dauphines ou oui ça va être mise
en place
vous savez déjà à peu près quels seront
vos prochains déplacements vos
prochaines actions que vous allez faire
en tant que reine et Dauphine ou pas
encore samedi prochain on va au salon
des métiers des arts
et pour l'instant on ne sait pas encore
OK et alors j'avais une dernière
question pourquoi cette fleur le muguet
est-ce que vous savez pourquoi c'est la
reine du muguet
je sais plus je sais plus d'accord
on ira se renseigner merci en tout cas à
toutes les trois d'être venu en plateau
pour d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
sais pas si vous aimez le cinéma si vous
avez beaucoup au cinéma
ça tombe bien c'est l'heure maintenant
de notre page cinéma
on va commencer avec le coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du septième art cette
semaine c'est le réalisateur Benjamin
pallier originaire de Rambouillet qui
vous propose son film favori regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter le
film Dupont la joie qui est un film
français réalisé par Yves Boisset en
1974 avec Jean Carmet notamment c'est un
film qui est assez dur puisqu'il
s'inspire de fait réel notamment de la
vague de meurtre raciste qui a eu lieu
en France à la fin des années 70 alors
pour vous raconter un peu l'histoire du
film donc c'est l'histoire de de
plusieurs couples de Français moyen qui
passe leurs vacances à chaque fois dans
un camping du sud de la France là cette
année-là il se retrouve tous ensemble et
il va y avoir un drame c'est à dire que
la l'une des filles du couple va être
retrouvée morte à proximité du camping
et à partir de là il va y avoir des
accusations qui vont être faites à
l'encontre de d'ouvriers étrangers ce
qui était sur un chantier à proximité du
camping
et de là va partir une il va y avoir une
vague de voyage de violence envers ses
ouvriers étrangers
alors c'est un film que j'ai choisi
parce que je trouve que il
s'inspire bien donc de ses faits qui ont
eu lieu à la fin des années 70
je trouve que Jean Carmet incarne un
personnage qui est vraiment odieux alors
je vous dis pas pourquoi vous verrez en
regardant le film et justement à partir
de ça
j'encarmé a eu beaucoup de mal par la
suite à la suite de ce film il a eu
beaucoup de mal de trouver d'autres
rôles au cinéma pendant quelques temps
parce que cette image de personne nage
odieux lui a collé à la peau pendant de
nombreuses années
c'est un film qui a fait polémique lors
de sa sortie en salle puisqu'il y a des
scènes qui sont très choquantes
notamment la scène du meurtre et puis du
viol de la jeune fille et voilà donc je
vous conseille quand même d'aller le
voir même si certaines scènes peuvent
choquer
[Musique]
une réaction
plateau suite à ce coup de coeur signé
c'est quand même un film assez glaçant
ça a l'air compliqué à regarder en tout
cas mais bon il faudrait peut-être
justement voir cette curiosité et voir
ce que ça donne c'est un film qui date
de
1975 donc en tout cas moi ça m'a donné
envie d'aller le voir on poursuit cette
page cinéma avec les sorties ciné de
cette semaine c'est Céline Charles qui
vous propose son top 3 regarder cette
semaine dans les salles obscures on
retrouve alibi.com 2 une comédie qui
signe le retour de la bande à Fifi
portée par le succès du premier opus le
réalisateur et acteur Philippe lacheau
revient avec ses camarades de toujours
mais aussi avec Nathalie Baye Arielle
Dombasle Gérard Jugnot ou encore Gad
Elmaleh si à la fin du premier volet
Greg avait promis à sa compagne Flo qui
ne lui mentirait plus jamais et qu'il
fermerait définitivement alibi.com son
agence spécialisée dans le mensonge ça
demande en mariage pourrait bien changer
la donne en fait ma belle-famille veut
absolument que les parents soient
présents au mariage ah merde bah moi le
problème c'est ton escroc de père c'est
pas mal le problème c'est ta psychopathe
de merde
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à croire qu'on soit là mais
c'est impossible on a jamais fait une
mission si risquer adapter d'une
histoire vraie et mettent-ils de la
réalisatrice synonyme choukou raconte le
combat de mamie-t-il une mère dont le
fils de 14 ans a été enlevé et lynché
par des suprémacistes blancs le garçon
afro-américain de Chicago rendait visite
à ses cousins dans le Mississippi de la
ségrégation lorsqu'il a été accusé de
draguer une commerçante blanche après sa
mort sa mère va tout mettre en oeuvre
pour obtenir justice cette odeur
monsieur c'est celle du corps de mon
fils en pestan la haine raciale
suivez-moi je vous prie
le monde entier toi foire ce qu'on a
fait à mon fils
les photos elles ont transformé la vie
des gens
maintenant le film d'animation
sacrémomie de Juan Jesus Garcia galocha
devrait ravir les plus jeunes dans cette
comédie des momies égyptiennes venus
d'un royaume enchanté vont voyager
jusqu'au Londres d'aujourd'hui objectif
récupéré une bague de mariage subtilisé
par un archéologue en effet la princesse
néfert est promise à un ancien pilote de
chars qu'elle déteste et ses réciproque
mais en compagnie du frère de tut et de
son crocodile domestique les quatre
personnages vont être contraints de
faire équipe à noter également que pour
les 25 ans du film culte de James
Cameron Titanic revient
exceptionnellement au cinéma en 3D une
bonne occasion pour la Saint-Valentin à
venir
vous avez une préférence dans dans ce
top 3 des films est-ce que vous avez une
petite préférence est-ce qu'il y a un
film que vous aimeriez aller voir je
crois moi c'est le deuxième le deuxième
oui oui
c'est ça c'est le Titanic en 3D oui moi
j'étais déjà allé le voir pour leur 20
ans ils avaient fait la même chose il
l'avait ressorti en 3D au cinéma du coup
là pour leur 25 ans il refait la même
chose et c'est vrai que le fait de
revoir ce film un peu mythique en 3D ça
vaut le coup moi j'irai bien voir à
Libye 2 il a l'air drôlement
alibi et mes petits les deux ont l'air
sont vraiment différents mais ils ont
l'air vraiment bien avoir et mais on ira
voir ses films au cinéma c'est bientôt
la fin de cette émission mais juste
avant de se quitter jetons un dernier
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir un ciel
voilé sur l'ensemble du département au
niveau des températures il fera toujours
aussi froid compter moins 3 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet et -2 à
Versailles et Houdan dans l'après-midi
nous devrions toujours avoir un grand
soleil ça fait du bien côté température
météo France prévoit 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans eversize et 5
degrés à Rambouillet et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]